I'm here with Latifah messin Sparks and
one of the great things about the London
chest classic is all the work that we do
with kids so can you tell us a little
bit about that your chest teacher right
I'm I work at school and I've been there
chess program and we have over hundred
children at the school and it's really
wonderful and what's the atmosphere like
here at the London chess classic it's
the weekends we have so many kids all
over the place and you were just doing
some coaching back in the VIP room no
it's great and what's amazing about the
classes they have the school events as
well over the week and they just love it
they just come they're enjoying it they
love the big board and they have a great
time so it's really nice now who is your
favorite in the London chess classic I
didn't know really III there's a few
that I like and a few stars a player
like but I don't really have a favorite
as well yeah what about the kids world
who do the kids like and the kids love
like Magnus Carson and they just love
the fact he's really young and he's a
really great player in the fact he's
been painful and at the top for a while
so they really enjoy that and they're
like I'm starting but yeah that's a hit
their favourite movie and that's how we
get girls into the game right the girls
like Magnus